greeting podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by on it
listen to me I live on this protein the
hem forced KOCO is tremendous you
understand me and protein easy to digest
tremendous also the acai vanilla don't
make me tell you about the shrimp tank
sport and the shrimp Tech immune when
I'm flying to take care of my [ __ ] in
I'm saying in case you bump into a
Japanese do with a mask on and [ __ ] like
that beside all that they got the
weights take out the kettlebells go to
Anna comrade now impress in church and
on the supplements only side
I'll get your ten percent off to live at
the house number two you want to take
care yourself one of the good parts of
taking care yourself is watching you
[ __ ] people don't know how important
it is to [ __ ] wash that muffler
correctly I'm gonna use right now is
just sitting at your desk stick your
finger up your ass right now make sure
nobody's watching pill and sniff your
fingers what does it smell like it ain't
no [ __ ] flapjack convention you
understand me that's why there's a new
product a bidet is making a comeback
it's not a new product cuz I hadn't
grown up a bidet my answer is beautiful
it's a bidet then they gonna come back
and they're portable because of who
hello pushy when you're writing your
Christmas list the sound this year make
sure you tell them to bring you a
portable a day from hello to she comes
with a 60-day guarantee which listen me
and Lee we tip the scales and mine has
been ever two years no problem so if it
would stand the stink and the weight of
my ass hello - she did they could
withstand anything right now for the
holidays hello - she calm and use the
Cold War Church church and I'm gonna
give you a 10% off your order alright
that's how easy it's gonna be let's
start right there and number three you
new year's resolutions to come and
you're a fat [ __ ] you need a guy I'm a
fat [ __ ] the key that worked for me was
Fuji whether it's a se Aiye chaos a cow
whether it's the super ito
whether it's the plain white one or the
blue one or the navy blue one these keys
are lightweight and tough of them death
go to Fuji sports.com right now and
press in church BAM I'm gonna give you a
10 go no I'm gonna give you 15% off your
order right now right now
today can something kick that [ __ ]
mule Lee what's happening you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here with his
favorite Christ kill Elise say yeah
we're going old school today it's the
second podcast of the month first off I
know you're concerned the fires are
closed by bro this [ __ ] started Tuesday
night when I was driving back from San
Diego I think whatever the night I was
driving back from San Diego Monday yeah
my Subaru is a tough [ __ ] car and
when I got the Irvine on the 5 which you
guys I'm hoping you're saying like joy
like me I know what a [ __ ] vine in the
5 is my point is the wind was [ __ ] so
strong that night it was so [ __ ]
strong so when I was coming home that
night about 11:30 maybe 11 I called Lee
I saw a fire trucks already so when I
woke up the next morning my wife you
know and you could smell it outside cuz
they were in Sun lens and Sun Valley
which is real close to North Hollywood
where we are now so you know my heart
goes out me they had to close the
[ __ ] 405 this morning I mean it's a
Messier guys thank God I'd have to
travel over the hill or anything I mean
everybody's got meetings today I know
for a fact the [ __ ] canceling [ __ ]
because it was it was even hard getting
here today
Oh have you ever driven on the freeway
when there's been fires I've done it
I've had it happen twice since I've
lived here a few years ago was just it
makes this look like a it made it like
it made mine look like a like a match or
something like a little brush fire but
like the side of the four or five maybe
four or five years ago caught on fire
and there was heat like I was driving
south so I was on the opposite side of
the freeway and I could I could feel the
heat through my window and that was in
it and then seeing the end of the videos
this morning of the 405 just completely
on fire I can't imagine and then a few
months ago in Burbank on off the 210
which was closed yesterday the 210 had
it to like just little it was a towards
the end of it but it was still like a
little spots of fired's you don't
realize how scary it is until you see it
you could smell it a lot of schools are
closed today
you know I mean
some of the schools that need the
[ __ ] clothes but the problem is the
air you could feel it some people really
react I you know I feel a little bit my
wife I get tasted okay
whatever you know I don't feel it that
much I didn't find the ashes on the
[ __ ] card it's really it's like yeah
I'm I'm less covered yesterday yesterday
yeah but not this small house though
I think whatever was close to us except
aventura but still my articles outdoor
you people what you're living through
and son it's a [ __ ] nightmare house
long i think the people came out to a
weaver walker show it was a [ __ ]
adventure you know and there's a
stand-up comic guys to do a rock venue
it's very hard because the comedians are
standing up the audience is standing up
and when you stand your attention level
something happens people go crazy re
likes to do those rooms I enjoy them
from time to time the tough in my skin I
just run through you know every three
minutes where's Lee where's Lee
obviously isn't my [ __ ] like I
brought them the [ __ ] backpack you
know and they yeah it's like it's like
they don't stop like Wesley where's
Lincoln I don't know he's playing the
[ __ ] Bongo somewhere do you see him
anyway around here no so don't worry
about and let it go
so but no you have to [ __ ] fight your
way through that it's not like being in
a comedy club what security comes over
this is the next word you say you get
thrown out see like you wouldn't even
know it's hand-to-hand combat comedy
that's called hand-to-hand combat Tommy
that's where you go when you want to get
really good you do 20 of those deals as
an opening act for a band and that's how
you just learned to [ __ ] get the
toughest skin in the world although you
know when I like uh minions have come on
the show we discuss Tribble runs the
reason why triple what makes the trouble
run so hard other then they're not
standard comedy rooms yes some of them
have a monthly comedy show so you train
people from small towns to come that but
some of them are like in sports bars
okay
so you gonna like Marty's eight ball
sports bar in Montana you know it
they had to watch [ __ ] sports all of
a sudden the comedian goes on States
that's called hand-to-hand combat calmly
they got that back to you
they're watching Oklahoma and it has
their back to you yeah like they don't
so that is one of the early stages of
comedy that's what toughen you up when
you go home after a night of dueling
calmly in a situation like that you
don't think about the laughs you got you
think about the people who had their
backs turned to you and then you say to
yourself you're not gonna go back there
but this is what builds your mind is a
comic you start going back there to get
little goals like when I started I
started a place called the broke I
started at the Comedy Works in Denver
but what I really developed where I
really developed my Tommy mind I gotta
hand it to them was at the broker
because there wasn't no going to the
stage Joey Diaz there was none of that
[ __ ] like I just walked up there cold
and it was steak night so was 1595 or
1495 for a baked potato a steak a salad
and an iced tea or something like that
and a dessert and then you got a free
comedy ticket so these are people just
went to get a state in the broker the
brook was known for good steaks Tuesday
night was slow and they just handed them
a comedy ticket with their dinner yeah
they just handed you thought you got no
the comedy show the comedy show was in
the steak room so if you want to eat the
steak you have to listen to the ocean
with the Canadians was the owner like a
big comedy fan or something no no it was
a guy with a wig at the time that was a
sweetheart of a guy he owned four of
them and they were all very unique
restaurants because the first thing they
did was bring your shrimp ball I told
you about the already and then the
woman's Bank where you had dinner
basically a little rooms that were where
you took your money will you take your
safety deposit boxes to look at your
what was in there in the box box then
they turned them into a little kitchen
stuff the little tables so they had a
curtain ladies and gentlemen so you
could actually go in those places and
have sex while you were eating they
would bring
and you can get like Jill down on your
wife it was crazy
well then I'll out it just thing kinda
happens and you give the waiter at 20
times they don't come back the 20
minutes oh my god and tell them there's
nothing let the little Mexican kid come
back there either you'll be under the
table eating your wife I don't [ __ ]
know Lee but anything is possible but my
point was that they just did it
triple approached him and they said yeah
that's to calmly hell I was very lucky
they don't do comedy no more and they
don't even consider it somebody would
somebody who worked there reached out to
me recently he said listen bro you know
we listen for the podcast and I just
won't let you know that you're not even
allowed on the premises Oh what did you
do there it ended good would not like
doesn't sound like it
it was just dog it was Mike it was my
teeth cutting it was a job I had from
December of 91 six months into comedy I
got this job and it lasted me till
January of 93 and I got fired
wow that's two years that's crazy so it
was basically an ass like a year and a
month or something like that because it
was 91 I had just gotten separate yet 91
was when I started so it was December of
91 December of 92 is a year and I think
I'm genuine anything got it I got fired
before the week of the Superbowl because
I pushed the manager into the
bookshelves as you walk in there there's
all the library books that's funny
because I was thinking about you know
you hear that song there you're never
gonna get it there you're never gonna
get it not distance by some duet a four
quartet from the [ __ ] nineties well I
started there at this place I they were
having you look at your life and you
think of the opportunities and how they
pop up you know I get out of prison I
get a job I become a good roofer I
become an estimator the whole time
wanted to do calmly but not having the
balls to even consider it like wanting
in the worst way possible
like just wanting it so badly leave that
I was walking around
and now thinking back that was what my
problem was they were so rager I was so
I wanted to do comedy so bad but I was
so [ __ ] scared like I get just
telling you this right now people I have
tears in my eyes and I'm holding my
thing like I'm gonna fight
I can't explain to you how hard it is to
live your life and want to do something
but you're so [ __ ] scared like I was
in prison I had my mother I had nothing
going on as a thief and I had nothing
going on I'm finally married and I had a
little baby and I [ __ ] got everything
going but I [ __ ] wanted to do comedy
in the worst [ __ ] way and I didn't
know how or but let's cut this [ __ ] I
was just such a [ __ ] [ __ ] I was such
a [ __ ] [ __ ] Lee and and and this
desire came just from the dice tapes and
like the doll and the commentary on the
halfway house at 89 and this desire
started January of 1990 this desire
close to it let's just assume because
I'm in a 989 89 I was in the halfway
house and I rented the downstairs and
brought the ender dress client a right
and at that time I thought it was very
funny and I was angry because I thought
that these are the thoughts I had in my
head for years what he was saying so you
mad at him that he said it or yes I was
mad at him that he said it before I had
the balls and it leaves just so weird to
me to think about you having fear of oh
my god
fear like wanting to do it and it was a
closeted thing I didn't tell anybody
okay so like it wasn't there's no way I
would say it because if I told somebody
then they would pressure me so let's go
back to 1990 though okay you're thinking
like you're like okay
open mic tonight I'm making no no no I'm
making seven hundred a week flat as a
[ __ ] estimator okay okay and I'm
making maybe
mm a weekend working the houses like
reroofing houses after hail storms why
that put half and add up my nose I'm
putting the other half of the bank and
I'm giving me the rest of my wife you
know the whole thing I'm living my
[ __ ] life I wasn't doing badly I
wasn't doing that financially I had a
condo I had a [ __ ] car I had a you
know I had like this life that had
always yearned for this was it this is
it guys right or wrong you just came out
of prison you've been a loser all your
[ __ ] life I mean you had it down to
you were [ __ ] 17 and then the coke
and the [ __ ] and all this [ __ ] in my
head took me into it a level which was
just disgusting and I ended up in jail
for it okay so let's just talk about
that I come out it's 90 I got this this
just pops up in [ __ ] six or seven
months you know it took me about a year
of roofing like nine months roofing to
realize that the company needed an
estimator we were they were the company
I was working for was my
brother-in-law's company but they again
were too scared to [ __ ] go out and
get work so they let the guys let me
tell you what was going right now so
they're subcontracting work which means
somebody else was getting the work and
keeping half the profits but I was still
making money so I didn't give a [ __ ]
until one day I was a family thing and
they're all talking about how all these
jobs are subcontracted by this big
roofing company and they're really
getting killed when I go then why are
you doing them why don't we go on bid
with them in the other way that'll take
us too much away from my job the problem
was there were two great roofers but
they weren't us there were three great
roofers the the brother-in-law and the
two brothers would were tremendous if
they'd the guys tremendous I mean when
you talk about roofers like I say people
certain people are born for
certain things I learned something every
day from my brother-in-law's
they would the to PO Box the Kings they
were brilliant [ __ ] young guys man
when it came to figuring out [ __ ] they
lived for that [ __ ]
like they went to work you know when you
lay roof it's not just going up there
you're gonna bump into different
situations every day they had done it so
long and they were in this if I was in
my thirties they're probably 35 36 they
were doing this as they were in high
school they knew these jobs backwards or
forwards they could do this [ __ ] in
their sleep right if they haven't seen
it they can know how to fix it oh my god
they were brilliant and all we did was
take off old roofs and then put on new
roads
we never [ __ ] re-roofed everything
was bright we had wheel so we would have
to cut the old roof take it off put the
insulation down put the wood down
wherever was needed and then later
rubber and then we used to do ballasted
roofs which means their roofs that you
put a rock slide you ever go to a roof
and they have rocks on the roof that
means that it's a ballasted roof that
it's heads rubber but it's held down by
these rocks so the rubber can then you
seal the sides with glue and you put a
kind of like a metal molding I forget
what it's called now it's been 20 years
I'm sorry and that's what that's called
we specialized in rubbery roofs we did
ha troops once in a while but my
brother-in-law thought it was very
dangerous you ever go into a place and
you see two [ __ ] people downstairs
with masks on and and they're pumping
the hot tar to a roof
don't ya things tend to blow up Jesus so
my brother-in-law's were involved with a
couple of them blowing up so now that
they were roofers they just committed to
that of those type of roofs so one dad
took it upon myself the contact like
that we did work with Firestone we did
work with a couple different rubber
companies Carlisle Carlisle was our
number one rubber
that time and I myself ladies and
gentlemen so you know thought that how
nice would it be if I could create my
own position in this company so what I
did was I contacted all the rubber
companies I told him what what I did how
I did it how I know about their product
and how I wanted to be representatives
for their products and they sent me to
estimating school so I think there was
either call out a Goodyear of Firestone
world it was I think it was Carlyle at
that time who sent me to a seminar for
like eight weeks I did this guys even
though I was doing drugs and selling
coke I stuck to this [ __ ] little
seminar [ __ ] and did they expect you to
only sell Carlyle and you were going to
do it anyway I was gonna sell everything
I didn't give a [ __ ] I was sort of push
Carlyle but if if they were set on if it
meant the job I would get certified in
all of them so that's what I did I got
certified at all
you know I hustled a way to get
certified long so I started bidding well
guess what guys I started getting jobs
it took about 90 days but I started like
I learned how to get blueprints I
learned how to read the blueprints so
wait so how does how do you even MIT how
do you even know people people just like
have a you go around house getting like
everybody knows I'm a [ __ ] stiff but
I'm a Salesman I know how to [ __ ]
create a position there's nothing more
than learning how to what do I tell
people when you call me what do I tell
you every time what you don't I'll put
the pieces together that's a true
statement true and true right now lis
your position your position are coming
in do to podcast with me and gone one
day you're gonna be at home alone you
know whoa there's a completely different
position there and I'm gonna create it
and I'm gonna make it I'm gonna double
my [ __ ] salary that's how people do
it ladies and gentlemen and you don't do
it by selling it you do it by doing it
and showing it to the employer and then
once you've made him money or once you
show them there's a potential for money
they'll let you create the
[ __ ] position people don't do this
anymore
my brother-in-law's had no idea that I
was even doing this until one day they
were like what were you this afternoon
when I said I went down to put a bid in
on the [ __ ] building downtown and
they're like what are you talking about
and I'm like yeah I got that bit in I
got another been here I got another bid
there I was bitten [ __ ] everywhere
and then BAM I got like this job I don't
know the numbers and the parameters
people it was [ __ ] 20 years ago and
like Chinese to me they closed the deal
so you were doing it for your
brother-in-law's company yeah
so I would go to it now I created my own
position I would go to work with them at
7:30 help stock the roof get on that
[ __ ] roof work as hard as everybody
else and at one o'clock once the roof
was torn up the hard heavy work
I would eat lunch at them change my
shirt wash my face and then leave and I
go on construction sites and start
bidding Oh constructions I gave me a
truck they gave me a cellphone and I
started bidding dog then that process
and I became a better now was not only
in the now I had my own job like the
opposite of selling so now they will go
now I became a stocker also so now we're
stocking supplies for the job so I would
call where Rocky Mountain roofing
supplies at the time I opened up an
account with them you know no I had my
own account with them and I would call
him up and say just deliver three rolls
of this to this place deliver these
tools this amount of stone I would call
the stone company and set the drop for
3:30 every afternoon by 3:30 we had to
be done with the roof so the stones
would come because you have to lay the
stones out that day so not only do you
cut the roof throw it off lay it all
down put the insulation down and then
put the rubber down on top and then put
all the caulking and all that [ __ ]
around and do the sealing around the
pipes and the air conditioners and all
that that all has to be done by 3:30
because it's 3:30 a truck comes and he
know when they in those stories and
there you are with these things up on
their fourth floor with a thing
connected to you and two
boob and rock shoot out of that and it's
you and me brother and you got to go and
spread the rock so take it and then
spread it you push it to the farthest
end and then you open up the valve and
the rock falls and you run back and you
load the rock that's what I used to do
every day that's race to do every day
man Wow and then I created my own
position everything was going great
okay I got a great job guys
but in Colorado when you're a roofer it
snows so the end those days you might go
fix leaks people have leaks like that
you do little repairs you know you're
always gonna have a leak there there's
always something no it's not-- [ __ ]
82 inches and also in the next days 90
degrees what he think something happened
and one of those days I was at home it
was January it was freezing at and I was
at home my wife was working the baby was
with my in-laws and I went to the video
store it was the first time I had been
alone in months and for some reason I
rented something but I read the
punchline it was a movie about staying a
pally with Tom Hanks and Sally Struthers
and I brought it home and the kid from
angel Salazar that was on the podcast
was in there bunch of comedians the
Wayans and it was a story about a comedy
club and I'm big-time comic and he
becomes strong yeah Roseanne's husbands
in it okay you know you know certainly
no I don't think it sounds a great movie
it's it's a great and see what if they
have a clip of anything from punchline
Tom Hanks and I'll see if there's like a
scene that really got me started when I
saw that movie that day I probably
watched it three [ __ ] dollars I
remember doing that what they like the
VHS from the video store whatever great
I'm like I watched it three times in a
row because at that moment it let me
know that that's right they're like I
was miserable in my marriage at that
time it seemed like
we didn't love each other which we did
really at this point anymore I'm not
gonna tell you that uh at this point I
was just a guy working you know I was
just [ __ ] working and it has a little
office in the back and I would sneak my
little cocaine from time to time but you
know beside that squirrel then let's see
what cuz there's a couple of things that
he says in there that were pretty that
got me but anyway it don't [ __ ]
matter so I watched that movie and ride
away I wanted to [ __ ] I just clicked
with you right away I wanted to do
stand-up and something happened that
they got a job in New Jersey your
company my company so all you I had at
that time the company was based out of
New Jersey but we were living in Boulder
they would do it a job in Denver and
that's how I got on it was an 18-month
job but the 18 months was now over I got
him a few jobs but now that was over
okay so they came to me when they and
they go listen if you want to you could
come to the east coast of us and roof we
got a couple jobs back there it might be
three four days a week because I have we
have to keep our guys employed or you
could stay here and keep bidding jobs
and we'll come back you schedule them
when we build by this time I already had
my little roofing company going where I
just did residential homes and you were
good enough just to do with you and a
friend being a friend to do residential
homes on the weekends Ghana so I had
burned down a little bit we were doing
the very weekend we did about 20
weekends in a row and then we took like
three weeks off we did another 10 and
then cuz he roofed all week right seeing
here oof to the big scale also all week
so the crazy thing was that sorry about
that people at little [ __ ] the
allergy that the smoke is killing people
so here I am so I go you know what my
buddy calls me one day in the middle of
all this now it's like February of 90 of
91 okay and one day before they leave to
Jersey they go we got one day on this
place can you do it with us
and I go yeah come on I don't give a
[ __ ] absolutely and then go get the
supplies for us and we'll meet you there
tomorrow morning at six well guess what
happens the next one I wake up in this
point two inches of [ __ ] slope but I
shovel my way out and I head out that
because the supplies are still gonna
drop and I will never ever ever forget
that day
as long as I live because the snow was
coming down so hard people that I
couldn't see four feet ahead of me
but I didn't have a jacket on why like I
had a hooded sweatshirt and oh I love
zon cuz it wasn't cold it was like this
really weird blizzard so by the time I
got I think we were doing the job in
Arvada and by the time I got to Evander
they had shoveled the streets the ladder
was up my brother-in-law had shoveled
the section of the roof and we were just
waiting on supplies so we're up there
and it's not cold but it's you can't see
you can't [ __ ] see guys you know for
me it wasn't called at that time for my
one brother-in-law he had a jacket on
and whatnot
now there's another two or three guys
standing around and I walked up and I go
on the supplies he and all sudden boom
as soon as I said that the truck comes
down the block and you know like what a
high/low they picked this stuff up and
then you have to get it out of the roof
and take the chain off it and then you
dispersed it to whether we needed to do
the job this whole time I'm on the roof
shoveling I'm working with them but now
it's ten o'clock the stuff comes and we
you know Larabee's the store
but everybody was starving but they go
Joey what do you want to do do you want
to order food and then go no no no
because they had green chili oh okay
well I would go over there right all of
the breakfast and while they were
[ __ ] preparing the breakfast I'd have
a bowl of green chili and I'd read the
paper so this is my last day a roof and
with them for about three months
it's February they're gonna go home and
you're gonna be out of a job
fine I'm on a job okay so I'm gonna go
home they're gonna go home if they need
me they'll call me but I wasn't really
out of a job I just wasn't have a few
weeks off to sell and if they picked up
in New Jersey I was going to go back
okay gotcha okay so what we had to do
this won't wait with the roof we had
done for 18 months there was a leak when
we knew there was gonna be elite that we
knew there was gonna be a problem it was
a certain section it was [ __ ] up so
I'm at the restaurant ladies and
gentlemen it's my last day at work with
my brother-in-law until I sell another
job or whatever I was not worried I had
my little side gig I had a little money
put away and as I'm eating the bowl of
chili there's a Rocky Mountain Post
right next to me
okay just laying there you ever been
ever consider the table ladies and
gentlemen there's a [ __ ] newspaper
there and I don't know what I didn't get
if you know the Rocky Mountain News it's
not like a traditional paper that you
open it sector of the New York Post you
open it from like a bug like a book okay
but for some reason when I open that I
went to open it to us what space are you
just take like 16 pages or whatever the
[ __ ] it is like you take a guess and
when I open it and land on a page and it
was a picture of a stand-up comedian
with his hand up in the air and I'm
microphone and it said stand up tell me
in Denver the new explosion
wait my [ __ ] heart stopped and how
long ago how do you watch the movie a
month but up to this month I'm all
[ __ ] up in the head I watched this
movie now I'm more [ __ ] up and I'm not
gonna lie to anybody I did nine-one-one
comedy clubs for one one comedy clubs
and I did call the comedy works after I
watched punchline and they said it's
Tuesday nights you have to call a week
in advance and I guys do you think I
called [ __ ] know so like that's what I
wanted to ask you so like you're like
okay call we can advance when you're
it's Tuesday morning and you're like
it's the day to call why don't you call
petrified of what I had the American
dream
and now I want to live my life like a
nomad ha I've been living in all my life
was I [ __ ] stupid you know I got a
wife I got a little kid I'm becoming an
estimator on my own Oh see you saw like
I saw that the career change almost had
a college degree but the school wouldn't
let me go back on campus because of my
felony and I'm gonna quit everything to
become a stand-up comedian
that's a [ __ ] pipe dream but I open
up this newspaper and it says stand-up
comedy blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah it's huge it's the
explosion of Roseanne now this is
February of 91 Roseanne was [ __ ]
hugely like in the TV segment it's like
a Thrones and just the throned Cosby's
Cosby's have been number one on whatever
night on [ __ ] for eight years in a
row nobody beat him Jesus would come on
playing the drums of the Beatles and
they still couldn't beat out the [ __ ]
Cosby Show and Roseanne beat him so
Roseanne was the [ __ ] now so all the
article was about was about Roseanne and
how she became a comic in Denver and all
what's going on in Denver now the
explosion of comedians in Denver the
open mic scene
they have a thing that says how to
become a comedian and they had all these
things that you could do but they had
one right there in Bulma and it was
starting in about a week and a half and
again I put seed out for the first three
or four days
and then it was 35 hours and I go I buy
cocaine five days a week for 50 bucks
hundred bucks I can't go spend thirty
five hours and I went I spent two thirty
five hundred dollars and into like you
were already thinking I want to be a
stand-up comedian full-time not lonely
not at all they please don't embarrass
me make me cry not at all I thought I
was a [ __ ] loser on a lucky streak
that said who the [ __ ] was I to be a
stand-up comedian I just wanted to do it
it was eating me alive how bad I wanted
to do it but who the [ __ ] am i late what
the [ __ ] have I done one of my chances
I'm lucky I'm walking around I got
people looking for me because I own 13
that allows and Jersey still and I would
be a stand-up comedian who [ __ ] my kid
I went to prison so what like what was
so exciting about it like the crowd
cheering like or laughing like what was
what drew you to it in the movie well
then watch the movie and when I read the
article but like what about the movie
you're like seeing that made you want to
do it the movie seemed like the book I
read in prison about Lenny Bruce it
seemed like these guy is that
drop out of society in a way you know
they all had day jobs but at night they
hung around this economy club and I know
what this feeling is like you know and
it's like if you know what comedy clubs
are like Tuesday thirst Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday are the off
nights and then Fridays and Saturdays
those guys are Chris D'Elia Joe Rogan
myself we come in on Fridays and salad
so Tuesday Wednesdays and Thursdays
belongs to local comedians and that's a
bond you know when Joshua comes on the
podcast and you guys hear us calling
back that's not uh that's not that's a
bond of 22 years of him knowing my inner
demons and me know his name demon so we
were there we were there in that same
dingy [ __ ] basement three nights a
week we can week out for two years you
know who has money you know losing your
french fries you know who's doing drugs
you know who's stealing jokes and you
need that that's what the character
comes from but at this point I didn't
know these things I just knew I wanted
to be a part of something away I thought
I wanted to be a criminal and that I
didn't want to be a little out of jail
is not the place to be if anybody's been
in jail please explain to me it's it's
oh I don't need telling me that no one
gets not cool it's nothing don't listen
to that [ __ ] your freedom somebody
telling you what to do what time to do
it nothing's worth your freedom so I
knew the criminality if I would do
something criminal it would be something
that was a send me to jail I always had
this chance of getting out of but never
again was there gonna be a machine that
involved
never again wasn't gonna be a two-ounce
drug by nothing I was not live under the
radar you want to buy an Eightball
I gotta know you a long time you wanna
buy quarter-round something like that
[ __ ] for me to make money I had a really
dangerous to me but
but I know when you're making a buy for
a cop hi every limb saying like I really
know these things so I didn't tell
anybody I I lied to everybody including
my wife and I would tell them those
doing something on Sunday I forgot what
I told her because at that time I was
still involved with the Boulder County
like system like the Cali system like I
started to go to meetings once a month
as a felon that [ __ ] they talked to
me about job opportunities in Korea [ __ ]
or whatever and and insane up in nobody
the class was that one o'clock on
Sundays for three weeks in a row I
didn't tell a [ __ ] soul people my
dearest friends in Jersey I told nobody
and then went every Sunday and I went to
the back of the class and there's
probably 13 people and I kept my mouth
[ __ ] shut
I didn't say two words and I think like
the second week we started talking about
ideas and he asked me and I told him
what I thought cuz he gave his homework
and then the third week the homework
assignment was actually to go on stage
that was it there was no [ __ ] around
what you believe a common kind out here
in LA they milk you the deathly
gentleman they put you through the
12-week course and then you perform at
the improv for 400 hours or front of all
evil agents listen there's nobody in the
audience and the percentage rate of
those people that stick with that class
are like three percent so my class is
basically a couple of like chefs real
estate people people who worked in
offices and
[Music]
that's it's crazy I'm telling you the
story you know it's just I walked in
there and none of the people in there
appeared like there was standing up
complex like none of them made the cut
from my visual I what it took like the
quake
I thought of everybody I thought
everybody had to be like Richard Pryor
and these people were just all to
[ __ ] plane but that did you think you
look like a stand-up comic no no I
thought guys by week two by week two I
thought that maybe this was a great
experience like next week I'm gonna get
to go up and that's gonna be great I'll
never do it again
I see you thought you were in a scratch
that edge and get it that's it that was
good enough for me guys at that point I
was so insecure about my opportunities
and possibilities but that was it that
was it I'm [ __ ] i'ma bottom about this
is like oh no psychiatrist because this
is terrible
I thought that know that this is it I
will go to one more class three minutes
you want no no a minute he wanted us to
do a minute look like kill Tony time
yeah it's go time
one minute and then guys that week was
the [ __ ] aura show I'm taking myself
to back right now like it was just a
horror show because I couldn't tell
anybody nobody you think they'd laugh at
you or what did you think I didn't think
anything I just it's like it's like
something what are your friends coming
up to him telling you they have HIV like
a that's what it felt like to me like
from the oh well Joey what you did what
are you [ __ ] stupid will you get out
of stand-up comic but so I did the third
[ __ ] thing
with her class third class I did my
minute and then he consults it to you
after class and I made myself like
number eight and what you did was just
outside the classroom and you went it
like they announced you coming to the
face okay oh no no you sat there in
front of the class and you drew from the
Hat the first time and I can't tell you
what number I was I don't know I know
that when I went to get my review so
after the class he closed up it was a
three-hour class and we all stood in the
hallway while he went back in and he
went you went in and he tighten your
reveal huh what you should do what he
thought you should do and when I went in
there he was a white dude from Long
Island
he was cool you know you seem pretty
[ __ ] cool I didn't think he liked my
Tommy and when I walked in he goes who
were you influences I say I really like
Richard Pryor like Hicks I like Andrew
and he goes you should consider this
because you should consider this and
here's my number if you need help I go
what do i do from here he goes this open
mics everywhere just not going all open
mics but I walked out there I hear
[ __ ] kidding me I'm not listening for
this [ __ ] class you're crazy you
weren't excited you were like almost I
was excited come on
[ __ ] yeah those are the words exactly
that I wanna [ __ ] hear right those
are the exact words I wanted a [ __ ]
here but then you immediately went to
and went home I went home when I looked
at the mirror and I'm like a little
[ __ ] blanket so I had no [ __ ] gig
so I open up a [ __ ] paper one day and
I see new comedy club opening in
Westminster Colorado looking for doorman
security bartenders blah blah blah all
this [ __ ]
so I [ __ ] got in the car and then st.
done and nobody and I ran up there and I
applied and I put Jeff harms his name
the teacher's name as a reference and
the guy called me that his name was
cruelly and he goes can you work
Thursday Friday Saturday this week in
the door and I go yeah and I went I
worked the door and they liked me and I
talked and did that now then send under
nobody but I got a day job selling
Toyotas my buddy talked me back into
someone [ __ ] Toyotas and I went back
to sound Toyota listen what I thought
what this place was was completely
different than what I had everybody and
any other car place I had ever been it
better or worse it it checked you when
you sell cars there's a lot of
dealerships that don't check you this
place checks you you're like saying Joey
what's a check well there's some places
you come in at eight o'clock you got a
cup of coffee [ __ ] we'll leave for a
little while you tell them how bad the
day is and then you go outside and wait
for [ __ ] customers or bang you do
whatever the [ __ ] you can this place you
got to go in there and run away and I
got a notepad and write three your goals
now remember we had Jim handy call up
absolutely and when you have to write
your goals down for the day for the week
and for the month and then write how you
gonna tame those goals so before you can
even touch a [ __ ] phone or talk to a
customer they will buy the book that's
why everybody wanted at 8:15 because you
had to write your goals you didn't want
to miss the sales call at 8:30 okay so
they did they force them to it forced
you and if you didn't like it you got
fired
that it was that [ __ ] simple now
again I had told Jim when I got the job
that I had to do something awkward like
I didn't tell him that was bartending
that I was a doorman at a comedy club
that was even too weird you like you
wanted to say something I didn't want to
say nobody the only person that know at
that time was my wife and she was like
you're doing what and I'm like I've
always liked Omni and I this is what I
don't know maybe I want to do this and
she [ __ ] looked at me like what I got
an 18 month old kid 16 month old kid you
want to try comedy if I shouldn't even
have to say Italy T I'm saying like
shouldn't have to say but it didn't
matter because I was making money so I
was blown money I don't know how to make
our jobs weekend more and be gone for
two nights
right then they offered me five minutes
away they said can you work the door
Wednesday Thursday Friday sell less it
sure then they came back to me a week
later they got a DJ quit don't we treat
me in the DJ booth and give you like a
two-dollar raise so I had myself this
[ __ ] you know but we're running the
club 25 hour a week job at night and
someone cars in the daytime writing
roles and one day I finally told Jim I
go Gemma I'm [ __ ] you know
I bought a tent they had a have a DJ at
a common economy those you don't what I
got DJ on the comedy club because you
shouldn't be DJing you should be on
stage and I think what are you talking
about he just proud yeah I've been
watching you know this whole [ __ ]
thing is Miss whole spiel so I was great
and dandy and this is after the class
this is after the class ha and then a
month later I go I sell a car and I go
in there early one morning to make sure
the car is ready for the customer he's
picking it up at 10:00 so I get there at
8:30 I like to give the the lot clerks
20 bucks apiece to vacuum it fix it up
with gas you know make it look nice for
the customer so when they get this on a
piece of [ __ ] and one of the kids was
Jim handy son gotcha
so when I walked back there he goes it's
funny you came back you know we're
talking about it on the drive here and I
know a woman when I do that he's a dad
mad about that I kept the vehicle
telling us no he said that he's sick and
tired of his life but if he had any
balls he'd [ __ ] quit his job and take
you on the road as a convenience you
could start your comedy career and I
couldn't believe it
I could not believe it
and again we this is April and I'm like
okay I'm going to call the Comedy Works
and I call the Comedy Works and guess
what I did that day and called me that
Tuesday morning Joey yeah you're up at
8:45 Monday light and I waited for that
morning and I cancelled then I cancelled
and I kept by guys that kept cancelling
any cans thing well what are you nervous
about what the [ __ ] do you think I was
nervous about Lee I'd like it
I don't know what just you're so
confident all these other ways it's I
it's hardly even picture it was I was
scared of the truth I was scared the
truth I knew that if I knew that if I
fail that this I really had no [ __ ]
options I really even though you had a
successful to successful careers car
sales and I was roofing how was it
successfully I was working like a
[ __ ] Savage that wasn't successful at
all who the [ __ ] are you kiddin I was a
hustler and
you know I was lucky I knew how to sell
drugs so from that I translated into but
I was just spinning my wheels I was just
spending my wheels like everybody else
does in that life and not even knowing
it
I'm not even knowing it and I love car
sales and I loved roofing and I was good
at estimating but I just wanted to try
it was like what you were meant to do
that so now I started watching
videotapes I just kept watching [ __ ]
videotapes at night when I get home
nobody was awake at what's the best of
be et no no no I'm sorry the best of Def
Con legit and I fell in love with Joe
Torre's company and then I started
watching uh-huh Rodney Dangerfield's
young comedians special and I fell in
love with Bill Hicks that phone Love
ain´t advice clad had not seen him and I
would hide these guys I wouldn't hide
these [ __ ] things I got in Wendover
you know I would treat him like you
would treat porn if you had a wife and
you didn't mind your wife to them like
that's how she quickly listen to the
Velo and Laila why are you yeah late
night with the thing I'm ready to
[ __ ] go to cable TV if she even came
down the stairs like it was just
horrible when I was you know asking the
comedians questions every week when they
would come in how is this life what are
you saying
you really have a family and do this
some guys had day jobs and we're still
doing it it was just very obscure and I
still refused to get on a [ __ ] stage
I still get [ __ ] canceling and then
people would tell him you ask this coin
to do a guest spot
and I didn't have the ball here I was
working here and they're telling me
asked a guy to do a guest spot and I did
not have the balls to ask the godly fear
will ruin your [ __ ] life if you let
it because we know it's gonna get you to
the next one that's when you're scared
the most when you [ __ ] know that this
is gonna save your life that's when we
get the worst set of [ __ ] fear that's
when you know that you're [ __ ] when
you know something's good for you it's
more that we get scared like I've never
listened then it's a great class it's
free but it's at 8:00 in the morning but
it'll change your life three times a
week you will refuse to [ __ ] go
because of fear because you might like
it and now now you're faced with the
reality of it like that was my fear like
I had a fear of failure and now with
limitation if I wouldn't have got on
stage I would have been in prison right
now there's no two ways of line to any
body here we could do the math I'll do
the math and running I'll do the math in
front of your people how long do you
think you would have taken were you
getting arrested again ten years there
was no way there was no way alleppey
can't change its spots
there was no way it took me ten years of
calm me to stop being [ __ ] felonious
for County to win you know the saying
[Music]
it took 10 years for comedy to win for
me that like when I got to the
Communists I'm like whatever I'm doing
as a comic now I'm a comic
no more stealing no more you know
robbing a case of booze to make 30 bucks
like the only person who was getting in
my way up to that point was me I got in
trouble in Seattle I had problems in
Boulder I hunted when I went home in 94
I was just a walking [ __ ] disaster
come on how how the [ __ ] but just
something something kept telling me you
gotta get on a [ __ ] stage and finally
my ex-wife said what are you gonna go on
stage finally she heard me call the
comedy works and she got a babysitter
she got a babysitter that night and she
put me in the spot laughing and she
[ __ ] uh you know we went to eat
somewhere or something and by that time
we were done we know it this was just I
don't know I don't know what what
happened I can't explain it
it was weird guys like I just lost
interest in anything except working and
this little child
[Music]
we drove to Denver and I got on stage
Matt woods was there and people came up
to me and told me at the great I had
great stage presence
I just Butley I just know that was more
heartbroken because you knew you had to
make a change or something because I
knew that I had done it that's it
I jumped over the hardest fence I could
do this again sure enough I got a gig
two nights later up in Greeley Colorado
felt like a paid stay in the people I
think he gave me 10 bucks for gas
that's cool final hauls for gas or
something like that which came back to
lumpy which came back to haunt me six
months late how I'm gonna tell you how
let me do it no no no Mattel yeah I got
this five bucks from
this was another angel I got a right and
my book this guy came into my life as an
angel he was there that man Thakali
works and he gave me the thing to show
it greatly two nights later and he
booked the room in Greeley called the
down under which they still do calmly I
thought excuse me and he would book me
as much as he could that down under
fifty bucks a pop and I would go then
just bomb later like you know and then
he would pay my rent based if I would
call him up and but we getting way ahead
of ourselves okay sorry so he gave me
either five bucks ten bucks for the gig
okay right and then after that this is
August this is July of ninety-one and
longest I did some bar and then in
September I went to New York and I did
an open mic in then in October I came
back and being my wife separated and
that's what I saw I let the cop the
broker was doing a comedy contest so I
went down there one that chapter of the
comedy contest that meant you advanced
and then when I went back that time I
had to figure it out so I invited all my
friends from work but they cheered for
me so I went to the violence and then at
the finals this guy Andy Payton was
there and a bunch of other comics now I
looked up to him he painted the picture
in that article in the paper was day I
opened that picture was a picture of
Andy Payton what the green chilly wire
with the green chilly and the Payton was
this guy who was very crafty he's a
mayor of a town now in Colorado
he was very crafty and he booked rooms
so he had made it to the finals also but
his big argument was that I was a
professional because that time Bill
Bauer paid me flowers for gasoline
he's probably good man this is December
18th of 1991 you're professional for $5
and they told me I was a professional
because I took that final hour pay for
an NCAA violating that and that's my
[ __ ] and I was but it's so weird how
after I went through that fear thing
everything changed in my life but I saw
everything bigger I became bolder you
know I mean would it take four months
after I got on stage for us to separate
you could tell that I was done so after
you go on stage that first time how
often would he do it oh okay
I was a bum I was a button I was a
part-time till I did it whatever I had
to go to the broker and then one night I
went drove all the way to Denver to do a
room that started 11:00 and they put me
out of one thing in the morning and
there was people in the audience oh I
hate such a bag of dicks I never went
out again like I said I'll never go to
open mics again I'd just go win that
contest at the broker every year every
[ __ ] I didn't know but that know-how
was fearful the whole time I was very
very [ __ ] fear for the whole time it
was kind of scary it's a weird how the
brain works so like even though you
brought like conquered your fear you're
still kind of scared of it well after I
conquered my fear of it till I ran into
another obstacle which was called
divorce which really changed the plan
because now the plan was like can't I
conquered my fear but that's as far as
really I was gonna take it I was
probably going to be an open microphone
time-to-time get on stage crack jokes
and that was gonna be extent of it I was
a family man but I know October 15 1991
when I walked home and she informed me
she was moving out like Felix and for
whatever it was weird because I was very
sad that I was losing my family when I
was very happy at the same time I was
becoming a stand-up comedian like now I
had no choice
now I had no excuse you saw he's not
there's like a freedom to do it like you
saw me like how quickly I doubted that
the child was gonna live with me I knew
I was going to see the child every week
right but I doubted the child will live
with me so maybe I could see the child
two or three nights a week and do comedy
the rest until I mean keep a day job
that was going to be the extent of Italy
that was the person who thought but how
quickly did he think about stand-up
write down she left right there when I
looked at that apartment there was
nothing left and you know right there I
was like so now I will have a [ __ ]
excuse and all of a sudden now there's a
contest at the broker like what a
[ __ ] coincidence like so my spirits
are kind of down I can't lie to you but
at the same time comedy was like okay so
that kind of picked me up in case I
still remember this like it was
yesterday I bought an acura integra and
went out and bought a bunch of music
I didn't buy furniture I had a stand I
had a TV and I had a bed with no [ __ ]
post like it was just two matches on the
floor I didn't even have them they took
my desk cuz it was her father's desk
they took my silverware Eppie wasn't the
testicle Testaments number I tell she
took my mustard that's [ __ ] out she
took everything
you know I had my credit cards and they
had a little bit of [ __ ] savings I
had credit and that was it and that
still it wasn't I was doing comedy I
became those guys that was drunk on me I
was getting drunk that was getting
[ __ ] up but every week I became Tyler
and Tyler with the waitresses at the
brophy after I became I've probably won
the contest
December 18th I won the contest and I
waited there were so many people I had
there that night like I must I had over
a hundred people that I knew from
Bouldin
I'm like working your friends work
friends people from the halfway house
but if I'm a Bose Pete's are these
hippies I know it was crazy it was crazy
I probably had really 75 of exaggerating
old car salesmen car salesmen from
different places where I worked
everybody was snorting coke everybody
was drinking and it was great I won 500
bucks or a thousand bucks him so I
called the guy a week later and I said
listen bro let's be honest you got that
[ __ ] magician in there now what the
[ __ ] is he doing for you and he goes
what do you mean I don't want you fire
him make me a house I'm saying he goes
well all I can pay is fifty thousand
week dunt dunt
that's two hundred a month every Tuesday
and I get to do County how long did he
think about asking him to do that short
days after I won the contest
but David deal wasn't like a
spur-of-the-moment thing or did he go I
had gone there every week to watch
calmly now and as a [ __ ] it didn't
take a genius at this [ __ ] magician
wisdom he was listen like I said it was
1495 [ __ ] noise to get a steak and to
watch the comedy show okay the ages
ranged in there
this guy was old
does it boulders a college town this guy
was 50 and he was to topple off he was a
really really really bad magician like
that that that that added insult to
injury not even getting got to the point
when the guy was doing 20 minutes they
would start talking and heckling them
and throwing [ __ ] and the waitstaff had
a [ __ ] him to fear a couple times it
was both type of situations Jesus Christ
so then it kept happening it kept
happening so I just called the guy out
of the blue this is guys this is what
you need to do man I didn't call the
magician and I didn't go behind the
magician's back the magician was having
a [ __ ] hard time there we Tuesday
because he was their host to the regular
show so now what it was was every
Tuesday two comics went up and then
Tribble would send two other comics up
so it was like a whole show like an hour
and a half shell or a two-hour show but
every time this magician went up people
would get up and run and leave that bad
you know y'all [ __ ] god-awful because
he had to be you know when you're young
you don't know how old somebody is but
now that you know about reflexes the guy
had to be 55 60 maybe 70 the birds
wouldn't come back the cards wouldn't
disappear he would give you like he was
one of those guys I would say take a
card and then go say it's the ace of
spades and it was really a red hard
lathe oh my god you know he was just old
so people were starting to laugh for the
money giggling management no I knew they
were getting complaints once I won the
contest I waited two days Bulbul that
made my call and I said listen whatever
your name is I've known you for a long
time
I love the magician but if you sit back
there it's painful on [ __ ] Tuesdays
since I won the contest and I'm a local
boy and I know people let me come in
there every Tuesday and hosts and he
goes let me think about it and I'll call
you back in two days later BAM I got the
hosting job the broker
and I was often [ __ ] running diva run
into that magician again no he died no
they still kept they kept them you know
what they did a lot of different
activities so they used them on
Wednesdays the place had a social night
we're professionals from around the time
will come and then bingo and like guys
were [ __ ] white chicks and they'll give
you free shrimp and [ __ ] then Thursday
was ladies night right and then Friday
and Saturday was just a hotel customers
folk they didn't need them but on Sunday
they the truth of the matter is in what
I lived in that region guys the truth on
matter is now I don't go to these things
no more because I really got spoiled and
I lived in Denver Louie loves what do
you call those things that you're gonna
have all the type of foods of buffets
okay
these two places to me will Fogle the
child before father the child came the
the place that you see in the shining
the hotel in the shiny no place where
they worked the plate yes I've closed
down right that was the best Sunday
buffet in the state of Colorado oh boy
Wow
people would fly in there where they
have to just had everything that you
[ __ ] wanted I forget Eggs Benedict
bill everything all that [ __ ] of meat
and the cut and chefs and people cooking
it was [ __ ] brilliant it was you know
whatever the cost wasn't at that time it
was well worth it and the second best
one was the broker
why did comedy at and one Sunday a month
was seafood so every goblin was done it
was still 30 bucks or you could eat so
they kept the riffraff out you know I'm
saying you're not they're eating those
[ __ ] Vegas shrimps and that type of
[ __ ] with the nerves doing it and the
[ __ ] Jew blood guts you know you're
eating nice clean shirt bro but they
would have a salmon
that was cold like Oh juice now like now
yourself and you would just go up to it
and pick little slices from it dad
how all I would do is drink 30 glasses
of freshly squeezed on his shoes it was
the best freshly squeezed orange juice
you ever tasted in your [ __ ] life
nice the way that we just leave the
thing like his 20 bucks leave the
[ __ ] thing don't take the vitamin C
away from a [ __ ] [ __ ] and blow for
three [ __ ] weeks and you want to take
away the container how is the bacon
everything like I mean I don't think I
went really in those days they had so so
much so action until this day do you
want me to tell you what the best thing
on the menu was yes the rice krispie
treats how would you kill a [ __ ]
for a rice krispy treat their other
Sunday sometimes I would go in there
before these irregular food how do you
like 22 [ __ ] rice krispie treats is
[ __ ] the whole tray oh my god oh let me
do some shoutouts real quick first Baba
Lingus thank you for the the box I love
you at all my heart I gave you a call
this morning and I saw then you call
them I'll call you back
my man fat Jesus my brother from a
different mother always got my back mr.
Jeffrey Collins my man man homie animos
Marc BJJ today
Natacha dissing your savage Gordon
terror whenever your [ __ ] ex you know
your neighbors and my man
Frankie [ __ ] piranhas the dates
are I got no [ __ ] dates I do
sacramento guys I come home I relax with
my family for the holidays we'll still
be doing podcast but like I said I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] ear surgery I can't
get the [ __ ] date yet cuz the
hospital but I should be getting it this
week I'll I'm here with you
[ __ ] till the end you know I'm
saying there's no big deal guys I'm in
that six the doctor said and I'll be in
the car by 10:30
Oh your favorite yeah the formula one
thing it's just like the other thing
they gotta leave something in there so I
mean for four days I'm like a little
[ __ ] antenna coming
here and I don't need nobody bothering
me trust me if you know me you do you
know I goo for myself I'll do a
periscope with you [ __ ] and
hopefully we get blood
pot smoke to come out of the tube and
then we'll [ __ ] break the [ __ ]
Internet but that's a completely
different situation I've been getting a
lot of different it's the time of year
guys it's a time of the year where you
[ __ ] go off the deep end
mentally sometimes you know you're
counting the days you're financially not
gonna [ __ ] make it you know you have
you got couples of cousins and nephews
and nieces and yet stress not the
holidays and you don't have a job or
whatever the [ __ ] it is but on top of
all that [ __ ] guess what you lost some
money like this year we lost a lot of
weird different people that in some way
or another you had a connection telling
you know saying from Chris Cornell to
[ __ ] you don't Ralphie may you had a
connection of these people you grew up
on Chris Cornell you actually heard
Ralphie may spill his thoughts and words
you know whatever you have for me it was
Ralphie in saline and God so many people
but it's also like I got an email yes
but I'm gonna get a bunch of emails uh
you know my men mr. ten stacks you know
you know people pablor Lingus lost the
father this year you know is the time
here bro were you going to how they
thinking it's my first holiday will have
my people went back and it's a [ __ ]
horrible thought because you know down
on that holiday you're gonna break down
this is your first holiday without this
individual trust me I went through it I
wouldn't talk to you you know mr. ten
stacks is mom that's going through
something and he wanted to know what he
should do and it's been lately the last
two or three weeks it's been an array of
emails of either that's Odie's and your
family members
and the holidays are coming and this is
it this is this is the deep waters of
life
the first holiday without your peeps you
have no idea because first off you think
it's gonna be so bad but then you get
there and you try to uphold your
tradition or whatever the [ __ ] you did
and no matter what you try to do this
that elephant is normal you know some
people don't even want to get up on that
day I don't know the first Christmas Rob
my mom I didn't want to get up on that
day there was no way I wanted to wake up
done that that's terrible that's just
terrible and we all think that why do we
have that thinking the other night I
would I gotta tell you guys you guys
learned from me and I learned from you
I've been tormenting Lee now if I don't
know how many [ __ ] years and you know
what guys Lee has picked up a weird
thing in the last six years and it's not
as confidence it's not this got a
girlfriend it's that that heats more
edibles it's nothing a widow lately cuz
he wants I had the pleasure of going to
watch Leon States last week ladies and
gentlemen and you know I don't blow
smoke up your [ __ ] ass
it just wasn't great timely it was
sensational clearly it was so
sensational but it was offensive to me
and that's what I realized how
sensational
his family was Lisa at had decadence and
I'm not making fun of him I'm not making
no joking and I taste him that night you
had a weird cadence of Bob Kelly louis
c.k and just are you joking right now
like no I'm not joking with you
guys I we went to this place called the
fourth wall this [ __ ] knuckle had
been going there for the last three
weeks on his own you pay five hours you
go up for five minutes
yeah you know I I sail early every
Langley gotta do something with your
time I didn't even know he was so
serious about it so this is knucklehead
two or three times a week he goes done
then pays five bucks next to a sushi
place and a bartender in school and
there's eight of nine people when you go
up on stage for five minutes
so last week listen I was home for three
nights in my house there's a slight low
but there's not enough time to do
something but there is enough time to do
five minutes especially when it's around
the corner from my house so I said leave
the me a favor pick me up and let's go
down to the fourth wall it's next to the
7-eleven about to go there later on me
and Lee torment that [ __ ] we've been
going every years there's a [ __ ]
Russian dry cleaner in there then I take
my action to I love with all my heart
there's there's a sushi place with like
a it's like a question mark you know the
rating is like a question mark it's like
you're on your own you know saying and
then there's uh there's a bartender at
school and there's this place and you
look at it you're like I'm not doing
comedy there let me tell you something
guys this is what comedy begins and I
want to go back in there and just watch
what open mic guys look like again I'm
doing it as a business now guys and when
you do it as a business it just sucks
dick and you want to just take it back
into the places where you just went up
there and told jokes and there's no
agents in the room there's no [ __ ]
it's just straight up comics and you get
to express yourself in a weird way and I
went down there and watch Lee Lee when I
first before me and he went up they I
mean there's some jokes about his
parents calling them and though you
don't want to pick up the phone even
though you love them
because they call you eight times a day
your father calls you to touch you but
the one special and your mother calls
you to ask you if you watch these videos
I mean ended and the cadence and his
patience up onstage was just brilliant I
mean he just did all this stuff that was
so original that I was blown away like I
had to go up to him I got him up to help
do [ __ ] lean out you know saying but
uh what the [ __ ] Lee
I haven't I really haven't done it like
that much
it's uh I've always loved it but like as
a spec I never thought I was that kind
of funny and I still don't even think
I'm really that funny things I said
about my parents does the first time I
said I just have said that that like oh
my god that they [ __ ] he picked up
his father and on the way back from the
405 that was enough now if it was up to
him he would take him right back to the
airport I mean he was good now I got a
fed that because I got no parents so I'm
thinking this [ __ ] guy's a dungeon do
any making fun of his parents he's you
know there's no lucky hits the joke then
so but it was so crazy how my button got
pushed for two minutes because I wish I
had parents that called me eight times a
day and I can [ __ ] torture them too
you know saying like how it just I would
flip it on if I was you I'd flip it on
your mom he's sure it's time for you to
start loosening her heart Connor eight
hundred and yeah well I just smoked this
[ __ ] joint that would kill Jesus off
for you back that would kill her but
every yeah but no this is it man you got
because that means you don't want to
hear from you now you know saying now
you're flipping the tables you see I'm
saying this showing about haha Saudis
we're flipping the [ __ ] tables here
and the last thing I want to talk to you
people bother is my boy has been we had
a discussion maybe two and a half months
ago here and we spoke about different
thoughts he had going on his head and
his wife and you could tell I could tell
something was going on it and he came
out and he
and then the like the true Sabbath of
the is he one group Island gather
psychiatrist [ __ ] visit how's it
going my brother let's go great it's uh
trying to think it's been I think
exactly three months or four months and
it's just it's everyone told me like I
might have to shop around a little bit
for a therapist and I didn't have to do
that at all really I I went on my
insurance
and I just I called a couple in this and
she initially told me she didn't know if
he had time for me I went in once and
she reminded me of my aunt a little bit
so it's kind of a little bit familiar
and it's really great it's so sometimes
and it's weird sometimes I judge when
I'm telling her I'm like oh this isn't
that bad like as I'm saying it it sounds
like I'm like it sounds like I am
whining like that's what I that's what I
don't want to do even to her but it's
been it's just been interesting the
bounce ideas off of someone like there
hasn't been I'm not that has I don't
think I had a breakdown or anything but
there hasn't been it's just been nice to
talk about the little things that are
usually just I'm going back and forth
all day in my head about it's nice to
just say them out loud you sometimes I
don't even listen as much as I should to
what she says it's just if me saying it
I'll say oh that's what I should do
about them so it's it's nice sometimes
just to vocalize it and it's it's just
working on different things that that
like I she's worth it something that it
I actually like it's kind of like how
you had when he who had the the island
of serenity she was talking about how I
I have like things that was like
stresses that get in your life or things
that you worry about the things that I
over the
they will go into one pool instead of I
should have a pool with my girlfriend
with my parents with my work and I
should separate it
and for with my brain I just owe it it's
just a constant like if I if I if I get
my the file up myself and not be busy
it'll just go pretty much all day if I
let it sometimes it when it's bad just
thinking about things I should have done
even in like like one of my curses I
have a pretty good memory so I'll
remember my stupid stuff from freshman
year of high school but [ __ ] that guy
or is it warm just like you like just
stuff negative stuff about me it doesn't
what that changes so often but it's nice
to be able to have someone tell you like
you should figure out ways to separate
your stresses and it'll help you like
manage your life rather than it won't
see it won't seem so big you feel better
now uh yeah I mean I don't I'm not on
any medicine she hasn't even mentioned
it it's yeah III and I don't want to
stop
I definitely like going I like going
once a week I actually I have to miss
this week but I'm gonna go twice next
week yeah I I look forward to because
I've had that issue for my whole life
I've always felt that it's very weird
that I'm doing a podcast because when
you say bully you think of like beat up
like in the like I don't know your
shirts ripped all that stuff and that
stuff like it happened a little bit but
not I was just more like in a weird
nerdy I was always fat it's just yeah
because I had the same issue where you
bullied physically or that were you
bullying yourself mentally did you think
that like you oh you think that they
looked at you differently or that there
was a little bit of physical but not
really like like two or three times from
my whole school eight like kindergarten
- so it wasn't yeah it wasn't that
and don't like what I was like what I
was thinking about it wasn't like and it
was a mix of me probably thinking they
didn't like me but it was also like and
who knows they could there could be
people listening that this right now I
grew up with that could say I'm crazy
but it just I never felt like I really
like belonged early I just I don't know
I just like occasionally I would go like
when my mom was winning her parents
schedule playdates there's that but once
it gets to middle school and kids start
scheduling them should stop it it kind
of slow it like I would never the way
you didn't want to do comedy I didn't
want to call someone up to hang out like
if I don't know I just it still freaks
me out
and and so I vote I always I never
really die didn't talk much I guess I I
but I would I learned I learned that I'd
like to be like that the goofy fat guy I
guess and so I would I would talk but it
wasn't I had like I always had like one
best friend who I would be even sort of
open with but not fully open it's hard
to be open what do you know what I have
like a lot of close relationships I
guess you know a friend of mine called
they grew up with they said I finally
listened to your podcast because that
effect was it's like telling him he goes
I know why you like that [ __ ] kid and
I go why he goes he reminds you Lube
doesn't it I go yes he does a lot and
the stuttering and just stood de
stuttering because when I first became
friends when we were 15 when he
approached me the first time he was to
ask me if I had slept the messed around
with his girlfriend
at that time he would beat me up and no
no no doubt about it but when he came up
to me he wasn't scared of me but the
stuttering so I knew because he started
like a lighter
while the [ __ ] with a and it's so weird
how when people stutter
and I I goofed on lubes all those years
you know everybody did the stutter and
you know when we went to the movie
theater that time Robert Plant was
saying the saw remains the same LeBron
oh you know all that [ __ ] but I knew
that uh I liked you because not that you
haven't had secured you just you want to
say something but you really then you
know that's how lose always seem unless
I got him fired up but well that didn't
mean nothing I loved where his heart was
till today I talked to loose you know
what's a [ __ ] week he calls me on
Sunday nights or something and it lubes
different with you than he is with like
well I love you but he still talks to me
he doesn't talk to anybody anymore he
Heidi doesn't want to see anybody you
don't know nothing on a job as a highway
operator and it's company promoted to a
truck driver and he's happy as [ __ ] his
father passed away his mother got put
feel like all folks woman she's reliving
life again
she's loving life in it and he's he has
to move out of his house he's got about
a year to move out of his house so he's
just living that by himself but
literally don't you know saying that's
great I'm happy that you went to the
doctor you getting something out of it I
thought you were gonna go for three
weeks and then that go back because
you'd be intimidated that's the first
step that's the first step to get to the
next level and it's nice because there's
really like it I don't know her from
anybody and I guess there's always a
pressure with people that you know that
like how they're gonna react to what you
say or what they're gonna think about it
and there's not really any of that with
a therapist like they they're not gonna
tell anybody who if they tell anybody
they don't know me so it's like
you sometimes like like in life like you
let like you said where you would lie to
everybody about what you were doing not
tell them there's no reason to lie to
her like it's uh
I'm going and I'm paying and being there
for my seller like that you just tell
them the truth and it they help you work
it out and they help you like just
realize just weird things just like
little things like I'm just like just
like even weird things that I always
think that people are mad are mad at me
which is weird and and one and one thing
that she said that really stuck with me
was like even if they are married like
so what what then if they're mad at you
and like you realize like nothing really
happens like nothing's gonna really come
of it and it just it it kind of helped
me I still forgot about it sometimes but
it's it is a nice way to think about it
yep you went over there as I could see
that you're smiling and then I would
leave you you look like the will be Gus
but uh you back you taking those classes
now oh yeah the ginger sweat a lot
better by the attacking body combat
you're going out to had seen people
people are seeing you here in the room
and they love you they love that you're
there they don't give a [ __ ] as long as
you're there they don't like the
[ __ ] that aren't there cuz
they're there they're in the molding you
know not knowing why should you have an
excuse where it's weird when you work
out in a group like that now the first
few wait you become friends with three
other people and they'll come up and you
gonna Levin thirty one with the other
guy class is way better than one so you
go there that for what happens like
anything else but they never see you in
those classes right and then it's a
[ __ ] pest that really is I'm proud of
him proud that you went around that you
saw in a podcast that you had uh you
know you were struggling with this I'm
also very proud to stand up and guys you
know me a long time I wouldn't talk like
this
it was smooth that night
this should've brought your dad was
money that should buy your mom was money
you know and then we only had five
minutes and you were happy you had time
you did it it takes a lot of balls to
look I just told you time how hard of a
time I had and 27 years here we are
laying it with all that fear it's still
[ __ ] there before every show I
thought there was gonna be a fire last
night there was a pencil last night and
I was like oh my god but you know it's
like I never wanna get on stage well I
really [ __ ] do you know like I never
want to get on stage but I really
[ __ ] wanted don't you know and it
doesn't make you feel better if I'm not
on stage in four nights like it affects
my personality of who I am I got on
stage every four nights it's like I can
take time walk how do I be able to take
a week off or something like that but
after that I gotta get on stage quickly
I feel the difference because all that
[ __ ] stocks powers in my head all the
stuff you want to say yeah like now I
got the notebook you know you know me
dog I'm at the place I sit there for a
little while I write I wrote a breakfast
I eat if I make a few calls and once the
food is done I write again for another
half 45 minutes and I get the [ __ ] out
of my system right so I've been scared
to go to any other open mics and that's
the only one I got it that's what you
need right now that's it that's your
little own personal commitment that's
what people that's what people will [ __ ]
up when they start going outside the
realm you then do it for another three
more weeks to err to the end of December
in January first walk another one on
Tuesday night where there's a bar and
you have to go and you may believe me
you may go up before one of the morning
but you gotta get that and get there at
9:00 and buy two drinks okay okay then
you got to do those those are always a
pleasure that there
you know that's the kind of [ __ ] that
you know or even odds show up with ten
people which you get ten people anywhere
they'll come support anyway
as where does it sound like the other
thing that stopped me from doing it for
so long as I got it I wanted to go
somewhere I like going there because no
one knows who I am
no it's perfect nobody's know who you
are all right so now that I'm anybody I
don't want them to just laugh because
it's it's the fun you know you know
people think they have that I'm very
proud I'm just displaying that I started
like a stand-up and I stuck with it like
a [ __ ] sad which I'm very proud
especially I told you that story tonight
I thought you know that you knew how
much I was it took so long for me to get
the courage to get up on that [ __ ]
stains it's ridiculous man ridiculous
and you know what I'm lucky like tofu
leash in the drug home to San Leslie
from the final little show of my man we
love Walker which uh that was the
toughest rule reeling Santa Ana was
tough on the Orange County lady they
were a little the way it's I felt like
we were [ __ ] like a [ __ ] wheel
walkers filthier than me for 45 minutes
playing music and like I said I stayed
the first night he was [ __ ] you know
I wasn't the truth I was with you yeah I
was the nothing we had one [ __ ] Jam
and we walked out there and then I want
some footage on YouTube he was great he
was greater than Susan and I hung around
for a little while and Wednesday I
watched the beginning the opening act
was great also
she was the experience man and I'm happy
I got the opportunity to three nights
well it's a little different but it
won't bring out a huge commitment I just
shake it up a little bit you have to
have a lot of energy they're standing up
so once you give that gap you really I
didn't really pound them down last night
it's like Alvarez on seven and how he
went to the body right that's what you
have to do in those ropes you go for
body shots you got to go for 12 minutes
of body shots when I'm just a wrist
so you're not gonna luckily huge laughs
huh
no therefore not like the huge laughter
it's a music venue you know they're
standing the [ __ ] up Lee you know so
they they have a last night that would
tip up you know every night they had
beer cans I mean these people were
[ __ ] sandwiches I'm saying oh it was
interesting watching that show after
doing like a few weeks of open mic it's
just like the difference in the rooms
like they were like it like you said
they were yelling and and it was it was
like the little woman is a little tiny
robot feel very safe I couldn't imagine
being doing something like that
well that's where people are wrong this
is like the beginning of jiu-jitsu
why are you sparring everyday with a
black dog if you're a white belt right
same thing you're just going over there
for a little time just to get your
basics down get your five minutes down
now with a few weeks don't we saying
it's her berry coulis
you've already been you weren't my
taping you've been on stage thousands of
time so that's like going backwards for
you but it's good that you did it
because they're you getting out of the
way right you can't go backwards now
you're over now you've done hope the
mics and you've opened up for me at the
Ice House you've woken up and realize
shot the special FL it's crazy yeah so
it's amazing that when I first met you
we started the podcast you said you did
not want to speak on the podcast I did
yeah and I still even now I would scare
me I think and now six five and a half
years later and we're doing open mics
well a [ __ ] process I did get mad at
myself oh my gosh and started the open
mics for four years ago I don't think I
would have been as good I think I needed
first off you watch a lot of specials I
am which you I could tell when you were
up there you got influenced from
different people all good I put my
finger on louis c.k really but okay so
it was really interesting to see but
anyway I like
said I got a shout-out to mr. Ted stacks
for his mom you know we're a family my
cats here to church page is cleaning up
a little bit people going there with
more straight stuff we got taken down
but the Emperor of the church piggy syat
put his back [ __ ] together but anyway
we got to take two steps to the rear and
get out of the I got [ __ ] to do I don't
know my daughter's ballet class so
please don't mind me and then I'm headed
to Sacramento for my last weekend of the
month but we'll be back Monday and
Wednesday night Wednesday night podcast
prepared to watch it it's gonna be a
four-hour 5-hour podcast here we're
gonna have food Rick Ramos is here and
myself and we're gonna show you the ten
films you need to watch over the
Christmas [ __ ] holiday just to get it
out of the way from Boogie Nights to the
Exorcist to the whole [ __ ] thing
we're going deep on Wednesday night
you might even taste the hallucinogenics
movies gotta have the scenes prepared
and it's all gonna be beautiful but like
I tell you in the beginning of the show
listen it's the holidays the new year
let's start it off for the clean [ __ ]
enough is enough already all you want
for christmas awesome clean butt cheeks
and a clean but [ __ ] but when you got
ax excess bone cones aka [ __ ]
dingleberries hanging through your
bowels you know saying and some fudge
you pudding smear all over your [ __ ]
your [ __ ] nutsack behind the nutsack
you ever notice you got that little
brown gives them back there that's what
happens but you don't need that to
happen because you can spray that all
away with to the touchy birthday you're
following me ooh
it's the perfect [ __ ] cleaner than a
white Christmas they now come at a
millennial pink and blue and they just
added more colors so you can add to your
bathroom to give it pizzazz people come
over they take a piss
they see that you got a color [ __ ]
tushy anything oh this guy's got [ __ ]
class being here this guy's a [ __ ]
Savage anyway here's the deal all right
hello [ __ ]
take a the way they're gonna take care
yes all this already I'm doing a dirty
[ __ ]
let's pretend you one is 69 what's a 69
we nobody because yes Oh smells like
[ __ ] one of those [ __ ] uh anyway
no matter where you [ __ ] smells like
none of your [ __ ] business it's not
good
we're just talking here but anyway for
the sake and given somebody a different
Christmas present I don't really get
socks everybody gets [ __ ] dies
everybody gets in here who needs all
this [ __ ] go to hello Trisha calm right
now like I said they got two fancy
colors and they start at $69 Santa can
afford that stop wiping your ass with
nasty [ __ ] toilet paper and get clean
ass with Toshi hello Toshi calm and use
the code church for 10% off your order
listen your mufflers going to be tip-top
Magoo take that from your uncle Joey
number two like I said he ain't gotta be
[ __ ] you gotta be up on your [ __ ]
supplements and that's what Hana comes
in the alpha brain come on another
percent money-back guarantee then what
the pilot in the product back heavy
force protein and protein digest so much
heat come on kind of that stop [ __ ]
cheating yourself it's a new year you
got new beginnings let's go
you need some [ __ ] help with your
cardio a little shroom tech sport you
travel for business a little shroom
techno mule
wanna holla calm go through the
supplements the [ __ ] jerky
sensational p.m. CT oil is off the
[ __ ] hook but you gotta try it to
like it understand me they're the best
supplements in the market gonna calm
right now impress in church and get 10%
off your honor and stop [ __ ] around
and don't forget you're gonna Joey Diaz
not net before you go to Amazon no
before you go on Amazon go to Joey Diaz
done that and click on the amazon banner
so we get Li a nice little Christmas
present to share it we can send them
away the [ __ ] long beats usually
somewhere nice and a long weeks from New
Year's all right you know we're gonna
take gamely on this side of nice on the
switch governments
just undoing the podcast and Russia and
take on Trump's information whatever the
[ __ ] please well listen hopefully I'll
see you [ __ ] the second men
don't if not I'll see you around town I
love you [ __ ] have a great
weekend thank you for listening
stay black uncle Joey and Lisa at we
love you
[Music]